problem 13 these eight cards are placed
facedown and shuffled so these are the
eight cards if Beatrice turns over only
one card what is the probability that
she will get a card with a number less
than four so all of these cards right
here are potential outcomes she's going
to flip them all over and then she wants
to she wants to know the probability
that you get two card less than four so
what are the cards that satisfy that
well there's three cards that are less
less than four they didn't say less than
or equal to four so it could be that
card that card are that card those are
the cards that she can pick out of the
eight cards that would satisfy this
constraint or those would be the three
outcomes out of the eight possible
outcomes that would satisfy these
conditions so the probability is just
three cards that satisfy your condition
divided by the total number of outcomes
so the probability of her picking a card
that is less than four there's three
cars that are less than four out of
eight cards the probability is 3/8 and
that is choice B always nice when our
answer is actually there okay problem
what's the next problem problem 14 the
Smith burg town library wanted to see
what types of books were borrowed most
often all right there there we go they
do a little pie diagram according to the
circle graph or they call it a circle
graph shown above okay let's see if
which of these statements are true the
first statement says more children's
books were borrowed than romance and
science fiction combined let's see if
that's true
children is 26 percent and then romance
and science fiction combined romance is
13 and science fiction is 18 so what's
13 plus 18 13 plus 18 3 plus 8 is 11 and
then we have 1 plus 1 plus 1 and so then
we get 31
so if you take romance and science
fiction combined that's 31 percent
that's 31 percent of the books while the
children's books were only 26 percent so
that is definitely not correct more than
half of the books borrowed where
children's mysteries and art combined so
more than half would mean has to be more
than 50% so they think children
mysteries and art combined so let's see
what that gets children's are doing a
different color children's mysteries and
art so see children's and mysteries if
you add those together 26 26 plus 20
that gives you 46% and then you add
another 4% to that we're combining with
art that gets us to 50% so exactly half
the books borrowed where children's
mysteries in art but they're saying more
than half this is exactly half so this
isn't doesn't seem right exactly they if
they said half or more then we would
have picked this choice but they said
definitely more than 50% so that can't
be it although it's kind of a tricky one
because it's exactly 50% see more
mysteries were borrowed than art and
science fiction combined
let's see mysteries was 20% and then art
and science fiction combined is 4 plus
18 if you combine these two you get 4
plus 18 is 22% so the mysteries are
definitely not more than the art and
science fiction combined so that's not
that's not the correct answer and then
finally more than half of the books this
is probably going to be our answer if we
haven't made any silly mistakes this
says more than half of the books were
borrowed were romance
mysteries and science fiction combined
let's see that romance mysteries and
science fiction and science fiction so
if we we already know romance plus
science fiction that was 13 plus 18
which we already figured out was 31%
these two could combine or 31% and then
you add that 31% to the mysteries so it
becomes 51% so that's right 50
1% is definitely more this is 51% of the
books borrowed so that's definitely more
than half of the books so are the
correct choice here is D